We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
Now there are people who like the David Pakman
show intro theme song and there are people
who don't like the David Pakman show intro
theme song.
What I have for you today is a candidate for
replacing our current theme song.
A viewer called in who has just a beautiful,
beautiful voice and sang what could be a replacement.
David Pakman show theme song for us.
Let's take a listen and let me know if you
like this better than what we're currently
using.
So David Pakman show, it's my favorite show.
You do more good dive, you know, the Jaybird
pack.
Oh, [inaudible]
yeah.
So listen, um, in all seriousness, if someone
can make either like an EDM or a dubstep remix
of that to quote Donald Trump from when he
asked Russia to hack Hillary's emails, I think
you would be greatly rewarded for that, uh,
with audience, uh, audience Karma, so to speak.
Uh, please, please, please consider if you
have the skills and I know that many people
in our audience do consider doing an EDM or
Dubstep remix of that and uh, send it to me.
Um, I would love it and I think it would definitely
make its way onto the show.
On today's bonus show, we are going to talk
about what Texas is doing to gun laws.
Right after we've had more mass shootings,
including one in Texas.
What they are doing is as, as w would you
have a whole bunch of people in the, in the
country who want to tighten up gun laws as
a result of the mass shootings that we're
having.
Texas is actually set to loosen their gun
laws, interestingly enough.
So we'll talk about that.
On the bonus show.
We will also talk about different um, daytime
schedules.
If there's a new study which says that one
in 300 people truly thrive on a very early
to bed, very early to rise routine.
Now there are lots of people who have adopted
that schedule early to bed early to rise,
but you can't really say that they're thriving.
In fact, it's really a struggle.
Um, one in 300 appear to actually thrive on
that and we'll talk about who they are.
And then lastly, there's a lawmaker who wants
to curb social media addiction with a new
bill.
And of course there are questions about, is
this nanny state liberals trying to control
us?
Is this suppression of speech of some kind?
All of those things that you would anticipate
are being discussed.
We will talk about the text of the proposal.
We will talk about its merits and much, much
more.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show,
become a member or become a patron, become
a member at www.joinedpacman.comorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com/david
Pakman show both.
We'll give you instant access to the bonus
show.
And lastly, the newest thing we're doing,
please follow me on twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pakman follow me there.
We've built up almost 10,000 subscribers just
in our first week on twitch, which is unbelievable.
And if you have an Amazon prime membership,
you can subscribe to twitch prime.
Amazon owns twitch for free.
Okay?
It costs you nothing.
Instead of you paying five bucks a month,
you pay nothing, but it counts as a paid subscription
for us.
So, uh, you can Google a how to subscribe
to twitch prime and it's very easy.
It takes almost no costs, you
nothing and we get a little bit of money.
So that's great stuff.
I'll talk to you on the bonus show and I will
see you on my next twitch live stream Wednesday
at 6:30 PM eastern,